gauthier rybinski est ce que on se
dirige vers une guerre ouverte
non il n'y est déjà sans doute que là la
question bien sûr nécessite pour être
pour que la réponse soit précise la
question mérite d'attendre un peu
quelques quelques heures ou quelques
jours mais de fait si vous voulez à
partir du moment où il y a violation du
droit international vous me direz
c'était déjà le cas avec la crimée c'est
vrai la crime et malheureusement est
passé très vite par faisait profit de
l'entente ou de la paix internationale
c'est toujours la même histoire c'est
que lorsqu'on veut absolument préserver
la paix eh bien on est souvent obligé de
le payer par le grignotage par l'avancée
d'un autre en l'occurrence le du
président russe juste une petite
remarque sur le temps on remarque est
tout un chacun peut être profondément
irrité de voir l'otan aussi
vos six inactifs disons le comme ça ça
veut dire quoi l'otan ça veut dire que
c'est une un groupement d'état qui se
protègent les uns les autres mais ça
veut dire aussi qu'il marche qu'il
fonctionne en fonction du droit et que
le droit s'il n'est pas respecté on est
précisément dans la logique d'un
vladimir poutine et donc c'est à double
tranchant soit on respecte le droit soit
on le respecte pas et en fonction de ça
soit on fait la guerre vladimir poutine
soit on l'a fait on voit si vous restez
avec nous il est 6h30 et